britney spears is celebrating her  release from her conservatorship by  tweeting out a fully nude photo of  herself this is not a great idea  it actually does undermine the free  brittany argument because this is pretty  strange  wacky self-destructive behavior now  britney spears is a pop star and pop  stars do these sorts of things so it's  not completely out of the ordinary but  the purpose of a conservatorship  is to put some constraints on people's  autonomy and individual choices because  they are not capable of handling their  freedom right maybe it's because you've  got some mental problem maybe it's  because you've got a drug problem  but  the idea behind a conservatorship is not  to take away your freedom but actually  to protect your freedom from your own  basest desires and your own basis  inclinations which will  destroy your freedom